president Trump and his team laid out
and it fairly painstaking detail today
they're prepped for a possible virus
outbreak in the United States but that
was not good enough for the party of
pain and misery what he's doing is late
too late
anemic hopefully we can make up for the
loss of time creators are who knows what
he's doing or she's doing to bring the
agencies together it should be a public
health expert second ask for the right
amount of money in bifocals I'm just
buying him bifocals so doesn't have
those glasses down there makes you much
smarter how's my name Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy joins us tonight
congressman that right amount of money
turns out to be eight point five billion
dollars Schumer suggested in a written
request this morning are they just
throwing money at this problem it seems
like Schumer just playing politics it's
throwing because we had all the the head
of appropriations by Republican and
Democrats together to walk through and
see what do we need and the interesting
part yeah the president was after there
today but I've been to numerous meetings
down at the White House bicameral
bipartisan walking through long before
anybody was talking about this and we've
been preparing for this when Republicans
were in the majority the last for the
five years we've increased NIH and CDC
funding almost 40% they know what we
created infectious disease Rapid
Response Fund Republicans created that
wondering if this day would ever come
so we have been preparing we have the
best health care in the world sure the
messaging of hit sooner should this
press conference have happened three
weeks ago before we would that have
gotten because all the stuff was in
place already but just you know people
need to hear it and then when they hear
it they go okay now I get it
well you know what's interesting if
you're an elected official you're gonna
go to your fourth meeting on this in the
entire Congress everybody together so
they have been hearing about it but they
were talking about it until this week am
I right or wrong on that they weren't
talking about it and these you know
feverish terms until the other Democrats
weren't talking anything about they
actually tried to criticize the
president when he shut the planes down
from China from coming into it that's
all my point is they're not gonna go
further than Trump on producting that's
do not from calm all they're trying to
look at there one of those teachers you
had that only wants to put a red mark
your paper instead of tell you where
you're doing it right and the president
has been preparing for this the
challenge is what did China do it
started in November never told us about
it we tried to send our scientists in
there are doctors positive on president
G way to positive in my view and how
he's handled this crisis I mean is that
just we have to do happy talk to keep
China diplomacy we've put our we put our
CDC and China actually copied our CDC
call it that
between our scientists they have worked
together it's the leadership and I think
what she has been doing it's been trying
to make sure the media is pushed down
instead of spending the time we believe
that it's our planet China oh you can't
believe any numbers they'll be a lot
bigger than what they're saying and
they're concerning once it goes to other
places that becomes a real problem for
us what about the politics of this the
president riding high after failed
impeachment conviction Muller bomb they
said a recession was going to happen
none of that happen economy vitals are
very very strong in this election year
do Democrats see this as their
opportunity they're there heck of a job
brownie moment there you know they're
there moment to season aha they see at
any moment to try to but compare this
when Ebola was here and President Obama
was in office you had Republicans in the
majority working together not playing
politics these are people's health this
is not the time to play politics Schumer
went out and just picked a number out of
the air just to try to go after the
president and for Nancy Pelosi to say
that after the president's been
preparing for this they're trying to get
away talking to the president about this
one-on-one
I don't you'd have to ask president cuz
I don't know if we're ever calling but
we've had all the administration down
giving us briefings we're going to our
fourth one just this week all right I
have to get your reaction to last
night's debate congressman the Democrats
are employing now a new talking point
against Bernie and one of them even
takes a shot at you much it adds up to
four more years of Donald Trump Kevin
McCarthy is Speaker of the House and the
inability to get the Senate into
democratic hands the time has come for
us to stop acting like the presidency is
the only office that matters now the New
York Times actually asked speaker Pelosi
about this today and here's what she
told them you know are you comfortable
with Bernie Sanders at the top of the
ticket Pelosi says yes reporter says do
you worry he'll jeopardize your majority
Pelosi says
no congressman should she be worried
well she should be worried because what
they have done in Congress literally
nothing and they should be worried about
all the success the president have she's
not worried about Bernie Sanders because
she has already surrendered to the
socialist more than a half of them have
co-sponsored not just support but
co-sponsored medicare-for-all
I mean this is a party that rather
commend communism than defend democracy
it is outrageous last year when the
president said we'll never be a
socialist country exactly you all stood
up and then and the Democrats are like
oh I'm not sure if I should sit stance I
have a nominee that's a social if we
only need 18 seats to win the majority
so the answer is yes so they want to
find it we have some of the guys from
you got you got a big recruit class you
got really need to go to take the house
comm if they really want to see a new
majority they can make it happen take
the house calm